Speaker 1: at the top of the show.
We talked about a vice news article which
accurately and correctly outlines how there
is now an open season on the trans community
as a result of the shooter in the Nashville,
Tennessee, shooting.
Being a trans individual.
Now, this, of course, ignores that If you
look at the last 5000 mass shootings, there
have been like three or four trans or non-binary
shooters.
Ignores all facts and reality that a drag
show where stories are read to kids, not necessarily
by trans people, just by drag performers has
nothing to do with what took place in Nashville,
Tennessee.
It doesn't matter.
It's now open season, and one of the primary
perpetrators here is radical, repugnant and
reactionary Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE or Marjorie GREENE.
Taylor or Marjorie Taylor GREENE, depending
on your preference.
She has now been suspended from Twitter after
a warning about trans vengeance.
Newsweek reports Representative Marjorie Taylor
GREENE claimed that her congressional Twitter
account has been suspended after sharing unfounded
information about a trans day of vengeance
in the wake of the Nashville school shooting.
As you know, the shooter ultimately killed
at least six people, including three young
students and three adult faculty members.
Police have yet to officially describe this
close or probable motive.
They've confirmed the shooter identified as
trans, although it remains unclear in which
ways and to what degree that was the case.
Nevertheless, several prominent conservative
figures like GREENE have attempted to link
Hale's actions to being trans, insinuating
with little evidence that gender transition,
drugs or surgeries were to blame in some manner.
Green in particular tweeted about a supposed
event called The Trans Day of Vengeance, linking
it to the Nashville shooting and alleging
a broader threat of trans terrorism.
Later, Green claimed her personal on her personal
account that her congressional account was
suspended because of those tweets.
The original tweet and subsequent ones have
been deleted.
But Newsweek was able to view some of them
after 3000 retweets of this tweet, my account
was suspended again.
Why is Twitter whitewashing the Trans Day
of Vengeance?
Elon Musk.
A day after a murder of children by a trans
shooter.
People need to know about the threat they
face from Antifa and trans terrorism.
In her own post on the matter.
Ella Irwin, who's the VP of Trust and Safety
at Twitter, said the platform automatically
swept four tweets containing a poster for
the Trans Day of Vengeance and took them down
no matter who was sharing it or why.
Makes sense.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE shouldn't get special
treatment on Twitter because she's an elected
official.
We had we had to automatically sweep our platform
and remove more than 5000 tweets slash retweets
of this poster.
We do not support tweets that incite violence,
irrespective of who posts them.
Vengeance does not imply peaceful protest.
Organizing or support for peaceful protests
is okay.
Later responding to a claim from Irwin that
accounts were not receiving strikes for sharing
it, GREENE shared a screenshot of an explanation
she purportedly received and said This is
a lie.
She posts saying that she's been limited because
of some of the things she posted.
Whatever.
Listen.
Seeing the right wing rush to spread transphobia
and more generally the anti LGBT sentiment
since the shooting earlier this week, it's
disturbing and it's depressing, but it's also
horrifying, of course.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is a particularly disgusting
and abhorrent person.
I would argue, even by the standards of the
average of the Republican Party, you've got
what I consider to be the more honest actors
in the Republican Party.
People like Willard Mitt Romney, Adam Kinzinger,
Liz Cheney, people with whom I disagree on
policy and who certainly hold some views I
find disgusting, including, for example, on
abortion.
But they are at least more honest actors in
the Republican Party that would call them
on the better side of the Republican Party.
Then you've kind of got the middle the average
of the crazies and the people like Romney
and Cheney, etc..
And then you have people like Marjorie Taylor,
GREENE, Matt Gaetz, Lauren Boebert, Lauren
Boebert, all of you know, all of these types
of folks.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, even by the average
of the modern Republican Party, is particularly
disgusting.
And as always, is the case and I mentioned
this earlier, and it bears repeating again.
It's always too soon to politicize shootings
when it's the typical shooting.
And what I mean by that is white male born
in the USA under age 25.
Then it's too soon to politicize.
And any discussion of actually doing a damn
thing about what's going on is inappropriate.
When we try to find actual solutions, when
we say, hey, you know what?
Had there been a waiting period and had the
person been unable to buy high capacity magazines
because of their age or all of the different
things that I talk about, ten different proposals,
then this shooting either wouldn't have happened
or fewer people would have died, both of which
would be better than what we hope that.
David That's too soon.
How dare you?
How dare you politicize a tragedy before they've
even buried their dead?
Well, when we wait, then nothing happens.
And the NRA does its thing and they do their
dog and pony show and nothing happens.
Well, as we are seeing now, they don't actually
care about politicizing these tragedies too
soon because Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Tucker
Carlson and the whole lot of them immediately
politicized it when it was about clamping
down on the trans community and linking this
to what they call trans women in sports and
drag shows and CRT and all of this sort of
stuff.
As always, they claim to care about the deficit,
but they don't.
They only care about the deficit when it's
a Democrat in the White House.
They claim to care about election integrity,
except when they try to steal an election
that they lost.
It's all projection.
And similarly, they care about not politicizing
mass shootings except when it's convenient
to politicize a mass shooting.
The Trump says at his rallies, There has never
been a movement like this.
And he's right.
But there has never been a movement this depraved,
and I am fearful of what comes next.
Let me know your thoughts and we will follow
up on this for sure.